what's up please I don't know what you
want but I just want my girl I'm scared
mine said yeah whack your work sir again
where's my girl I don't know why you
this is antagonizing you so much I just
want my wife
[Music]
my boys and girls we're back with
another Banger and as we do we get
straight to the nitty gritty
titty
no we get straight to it you get
straight no
we get straight to it um guys the
question of the week was
how did you find out you were the side
piece
obviously as you already know guys
that's specific that's incredibly
specific wow as you know answers were
just so juicy so as per I'm just going
to reel them off I'm gonna
cool how did you find out you were the
side piece when his wife called me
directly and asked to speak to him
that's impossible I promise you now
called me directly and asked to speak to
him
she's got the whole game bro
she's like a whole game size I can't be
in that scenario I can't be any of them
three in that yeah
cheating husband and I can't be deciding
build me directly hello [ __ ] can I speak
to fuhad please
can I speak to my husband please
it's your wife
I could be just lighting down if you say
it's my wife be like what it's your wife
bro you don't know what to say I was I
would have to because you're
incriminating yourself yeah
this whole thing
incrimination because she can hear you
I'd be like who's trying to play who I'm
Gonna Keep stuff yeah I'm gonna hold my
lips and talk to my eyes
I mean do you start doing up SOS with my
eyelids just like bare blinking they're
Morse I'm having a seizure on the spot
they're Moss because that's nonsense
oh I think so because I'll just I'll
just say Ain't Got Away
had a wife had a wife
my goodness
um when I get a text when I get when I
got a text from her mum saying you'll
never be as good as her real man
all this mum stuff where moms are invest
their way to invested the mums are way
too invested no mother can text me to
tell me about her daughter you'll never
be was it you're never as good as her
real man real man never be as and you
had no idea she had a real man
big man that's what's that all about
what's that all about family coming out
your mom's a [ __ ] just so you know FYI
you're almost done by the way FYI never
let your mum intervene in this again
because she's just breaking bad yeah
your mum's blocking you're almost
blocking and she's a hater she's a
frankly she's very rude
frankly she's very direct and very rude
tell her to delete my number I don't
know how she got it and who's this real
man yeah the real real man I ain't seen
it yeah yeah he wasn't there oh he
didn't pick you up in fact I picked you
up yeah and dropped you off so when
they're giving you money when you needed
it where is he where is this real man
who are you talking about that's G wagon
dog
I couldn't be confronted with that he's
picking me up in a minute G wagon just
see you again just pulls up I'm slashing
the tires because you're legless I'm
smashing the tires 100
and I'm running off yeah them tires are
way better oh they are that's the thing
as well I'll probably try to stab it my
wrist will collapse under it and I'll
just sit there and cry I was actually
parked by the G-Wagon when I went to
highg over my mum the other day
um poked my hand I was thinking yo this
car is massive this car is actually we
actually stood next to one this car is
massive did you know they were
originally like military vehicles it
makes sense they used to be armored
plated oh when they were just the way
they were designed they were designed to
be military like off-road videos yeah
that makes sense that it looks like like
a dune buggy types type yeah it makes
sense yeah these Kardashians said run me
that and now it's dead it's their go-to
that's their expediting
GE class say less
um I heard her yell we didn't order food
when I knocked on her front door
how did you find out you were in a side
piece just to refresh people's memory
me as the side I didn't know I'm the
side I'm knocking on the doctor we
didn't we didn't order food oh her man's
in there yeah oh her man's in there say
less
also her man ain't asking enough
questions yeah that's also a twisted
double on top we didn't order didn't
order food
so I'm nothing but a snack is what
you're telling me I snag that you're not
in the mood for it's a little dip for
you oh we didn't we we didn't order food
no it's wrong you'll hear me so open
hand smack the door
open this door actual factual I've been
coming here every week we didn't order
food and Maine is so deep into Tom that
he don't care who's at the door family
doesn't care answer me don't answer it's
your business we're here together
we did not affair
ah bro that reminds me of uh oh bro
that's not in Hill do you remember that
you ever seen nothing Hill yeah but I
got along oh where
um home girl goes upstairs to the hotel
they go on a date he goes about upstairs
to the hotel she's in the Ritz or
something she goes upstairs and she says
come to my room in five minutes okay
okay let me spruce up he knocks on the
door you've got knocks on the door
nervous nervous and her Mane opens the
door I think I remember her main opens
the door yeah he has to play the part
yeah and he says no no she Julia Roberts
opens the door but the Main's there and
he says while God who's at the door and
then the Hugh Grant jumps in says oh
it's room service I'm just clocking off
for the night see if you man needed
anything the man gives him the garbage
he says take out the trash
is staring at him I'm so sorry please he
grabs Julia from behind rests the head
on her shoulder like yeah slips you've
got a 20.
not even in pounds in dollars oh grabs
her from behind you guys are from behind
on shoulder she said and he's like did
you like the surprise good surprise or
bad surprise me being here and she's
like good surprise I'm just looking
she's just looking at huge like don't
say a word shut your mouth for all of us
please it's long for all of us Play Your
Part Monday we'll play the part so
Prosper eggs
mandam will actually play the part until
you until you give me your trash
until you give me your because that's
too much of a like a physical
representation of my feelings
do I mean because you've just given me
myself yeah yeah you gave me the trash
I'll flip it out of his hand
and he'd be like what's going on I would
want to start suing people oh the Ritz
is going to hear about this tonight
management get your manager in here now
what man is shut your mouth I've been
managing that too whilst you've been
away yeah I've been clocking in your
clothes
oh I'm talking about managing I've been
managing her guts for the last four
weeks my God how about that stay out my
face
oh we will get physical oh 100 will get
physical he'll grab me here and I'll
panic
I will leave you lately he'll describe
me by the scuffing my neck and I'll
panic
I'm allowed to get a jacket a jacket
yeah yeah he's coming he's coming he's
coming
Duty managers coming Jeep managers oh
[ __ ] oh no one I'm no one I'm no one
that killed me fair play well we're only
on number three wow say less ah
okay how did you find out you were the
side piece tell me why his cousin is
wearing all of his hoodies please
foreign
oh dear
oh damn ones man said this is cousin ten
ones them ones wearing all of his
hoodies
that's a bait one girls need to keep
their hands off the hoodies bro bro keep
their hands off the hoodies bro because
it's your bait in my life bro
anyway
when I was over at his place a girl came
over we both started to scream at him he
had to leave
she just that was it came over and they
just started arguing he had to leave he
just left them both there said you men
are doing too much
that literally it's long I'm gone I
patterned two I can pattern a third I'm
just gonna start again I'm gonna talk
this up to a loss yeah yeah charge it to
the game yeah yeah charge it to the game
I'm gone I'm gone fast charge it to the
game [ __ ] charge it to the game
funny I told my friends about him he
called me to tell me to never do that
again
facts
[ __ ] keep my name out your mouth in
these streets
what do you think you're doing
whatever you're doing what kind of
expose age you think this is
why are you doing up TMZ keep your mouth
shut
baiting me out like that
cause I let her never do that again
it's so funny wow
ah I told my friends about him
[Laughter]
hey yo never do that again
don't let this come back to me again
keep your mouth shut
and the only thing she caught was that
is like I'm exciting facts that's the
only one wow Revelation I'm exciting as
he's screaming at her as the spit's
literally coming through the phone
or some Tom and Jerry
she's like wow I'm a side table she has
to go and tell her friends again now
that oh remember I just remember I said
yeah yeah it's not it's not real okay
forget it yeah yeah yeah don't do that
again
he's posting it's cool but never
actually vile
the confidence the confidence to ring
around and say don't do that again her
own friends a break for confidence how
did it Circle back to him which friend
run their mouth how did it Circle back
to him oh God that's Joe the mission's
too small
[Laughter]
oh Jesus oh god oh jeez
um he posted I'm gonna do the most for
her on Friday but we didn't have any
plans
laughs
oh wow he didn't give a [ __ ] he said
this I'm done with this secret life I
need to come clean it's killing me week
in week out my back is killing me I
can't shoulder this anymore
on Friday I love her I actually love her
and this dog life is behind me side
[ __ ] was like Friday came when Friday
came in and I didn't hear from him
nothing not even a what's something
nothing good morning nothing
they came and went
oh never never never never I'm gonna do
the man was tired of this dog life
I can speak on past experience the load
Bears heavy the load starts to Bear
heavy bro
oh yo heavy is the head that wears the
crown facts yeah man came clean on
socials
this is the funniest question bro
every single one we've gone into Deets
bro and that's only what seven oh I've
got a way to go oh God
after seven months of dating him I woke
up to a woman standing over me and my
key card
my key card my car keyed sorry she
walked my ass then and there
I woke up to a woman standing over me
and my car and my car's been keyed to
pieces and then she beat the [ __ ] out of
me yeah that same day
[ __ ] I can't wake up someone standing
over me first and foreign
into your face
uncontrollably
after seven months of a happy
relationship some random hoe just starts
beating the [ __ ] out of you bending over
you in your bed
where was my man he dipped out at 6am
all right go he's gone he saw his Mrs
pull up and said no
ah I'm sure it won't be that bad I'm
sorry yeah it's gonna be Chit Chat yeah
if I'm here I'm just going to antagonize
it yeah yeah I need to step out
little did he know
she got murked oh Bell in his line he
blocked her immediately immediately the
number you have doubt is not oh my days
uh next one he celebrated Valentine's
Day with me on February 15th
laughs
[Applause]
oh no oh my God that's too funny it's so
simple yet oh February that means a lot
February 15th oh yeah [ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah you're pissed you're pissed you're
pissed
that's fast I couldn't care less about
Valentine's day but if don't you dare
you plan anything with me on the 15th
fam you're taking a piss family what
were you doing yesterday yeah just air
me all together what were you doing
yesterday
you know what I was doing yesterday and
I had no choice here from a horse's
mouth yeah I have to hear it from the
horse's mouth or else we're still dating
whatever you say I'm still oh God
that's jokes my abs are killing me Fam
he texted her he texted her he was
working late whilst he was lying next to
me
man didn't even have that privacy screen
I'm working late working late she just
prayed the whole thing like wow
them once I couldn't be told I couldn't
I don't know how I'd feel facing this
fact that I'm deciding facing this
because I think I'm in a relationship
yeah yeah yeah I don't think I can
stomach that
if I genuinely believe I'm in a
relationship like all roads lead to this
sign and she's like and I find out any
which way like for one of these ones
we've read out today
I just don't know if I'm going to
survive that night
I generally don't think I'm going to
survive that night James
because if I'm seven months for example
seven months that's an investment well
we we basically live together seven
months we're living together now
and then I just wake up morning and
there's just a big brother looking over
me why in my own yard bro I'm not even
checked outside team yeah yeah yeah all
you can see is nice gray paint under his
key that's in his hand curled up gray
paint oh yeah they're black oh yeah
that's that's my car shavings I know
that's why yeah I know that color
and man doesn't speak just whack whack
whack what's going on and where's my
girlfriend
is he like your who your who whack all
of that again big man what's she called
so I don't know who you are sir but
where's my girlfriend
handshaking sir I'm I don't know what
you want calling any man's sir in my
yard that's that's ready to fight me I'm
not calling him sir sir please
I don't know what you want but I just
want my girl I'm scared mine said yeah
whack your work sir again where's my
girl I don't know why you this is
antagonizing you so much I just want my
wife all these days
that's hilarious Jesus when he got a
phone call and woke me up in the middle
of the night to drop me home
pressure that the pressure was really
that's a horrible drive home wake up
wake up wake up wake up wake up wake up
wake up wake up
whatever you thought was gonna happen in
the morning we have to go now and fam we
have to go now get your [ __ ] together
immediately yeah I have to take you home
now why I just have to get your stuff I
have to take you home I'd raise my voice
yeah he's so angry at her yeah yeah yeah
yeah even though I'm the dog yeah of
course you're [ __ ] up everything
is so quickly when you're in cheat she
is the enemy enemy she's been difficult
are you crazy
do you know who you are in this diet
Play Your Part you're a stranger in my
yard get out get your stuff and leave
yeah dude why do I have to ask you twice
get up
oh God we've hardly heard any girl once
we've hardly heard any go once the next
one I saw her drive in my Range Rover
say that one more time I saw her driving
my Range Rover
I don't even know how to unpick that
so exactly exactly exactly hang on
exactly
man said this babe Happy Birthday this
is your range
but Imma hold on to it
Mondays Wednesdays and Fridays mine's in
the shop mine's on order I ordered the
same one we're gonna be sharing this for
a little bit she said babe obviously you
pay for it have it it's ours she's at
Co-op and all of a sudden some next
things just spitting hers
so that's my range
wow oh he is Savage brother he bought
the same thing this he bought two things
the same car
he's uh he's either African or Saudi
Persian or satin
makes perfect sense
huh I told him to go text his hoes he
ended up texting me
that's when she realized boy
wow text your hoes safe hi
[Music]
that just smells like jokes
his mum pulled me to the side and told
me the Mane was there
his
his mom pulled me to the side and says
here stops at what fam keep your voice
down his main goes here stop stop
what
and the thing is girls will just play it
for him for a split second they'll play
it and then they're just they're
figuring out how where's the big reveal
yeah yeah yeah man them will just hold
it we have to I'm not walking in a yard
and I'm like oh hi how's it going she's
like her man's here
her man is here hamasi
however
yeah all right say less yeah I'll just
turn around yeah whatever man
but I have to I have to put eyes on it
oh yeah yeah Point them out to me yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah and you can't be the
biggest guy here
and it can't be who I think yeah at
least let me know that I'm like she
couldn't help herself with me if I'm the
side let her know she couldn't help
herself yeah yeah yeah I can't see some
stack is rare because I'm like so why
even play with me yeah why bother with
me that's a man
why have you been wasting your time with
me what didn't he do
what doesn't he do yeah I mean like why
are you coming to me uh cause trouble
like that
when he turned the lights off in my
apartment because his wife was outside
she tracked his phone
his wife was outside
and the lights off in her apartment
all of a sudden the lies are going off
she's like what what are you doing
[Music]
you can't even say what
shut up and sit down little role play
yeah I'm the I'm the danger man
don't speak we're being robbed oh my God
his wife is outside tracked his phone
brother I'm leaving my phone on the
carpet I'm dipping the coffee but your
car's there oh something's probably
there she can't park next to my car
behind your costume don't reverse out
bro I'll open the window up babe no
[Applause]
[Laughter]
I'll open it with a straight away and
confess everything
is dangerous
it's too dangerous I don't like that
kind of Confrontation
she'll murk your car I she said rage
babe stop stop stop turn around turn
around
yeah and I'm never coming home
I'm never coming home oh God
when his brother invited me sorry when
his brother invited me to his wedding
two weeks from now
so they're still she doesn't realize yet
they're still convoluted wow
when her man called whilst I was beaten
and she told me to slow down so she
could answer
foreign
she said it's Westview if I don't answer
this phone I promise you now I don't
care what we're doing it's worse for you
it's worse for you if I don't answer
this phone sorry not even stop slow down
so I can answer this call
I mean what's what's what's all of this
what is all of this I'm me
it's worse for you if I don't ask
I don't even know what that means
um who is this I can't hear that that
will petrify me that will actually
petrify me
oh when his wife turned up to my baby
scan
no
certain wives need to mind their
business do you know what I mean
so wives just need to mind their
business that's taking it too far too
far regardless of whose baby this is
this is a special moment for her I have
to scan in peace turn up to my baby scan
for that what are you trying to do we're
in hospital bro stop whatever you want
to do stop let's think about this let's
actually this is not about you it really
is there's a life yeah yeah yeah yeah
this isn't about you you're just draw
you're doing up drama stops ruining my
baby Scott
his wife turned up to my baby scan just
the OB GYN just watching praying
that's mad the mat the bread's like
this is why I cheat because you're just
doing the most you're crazy you're doing
out Dramatics how did you even find out
about this appointment
relax
hacking my shared calendar the facts
stop oh my God everything you're doing
his cousin casually mentioned his
engagement and when I confronted him he
said and
you're engaged you do know I'm dating
your cousin right you're telling me he's
engaged
and and your point being you fam you do
know you're the side chick yeah have you
never heard of a side chick
and that's your business and
well I'm not allowed to have no more
conversations because you're here
I didn't even know you like that
I'm gonna speak to my cousin the way I
want to speak to my friends about
oh God his Mane kept commenting on his
insta posts and I confronted him he said
I thought you knew
[Laughter]
no I thought I thought you knew she's
been commented on who did you think it
was perks I thought you were carburetor
so this is why this is working who is
this girl that keeps commenting on the
same babe this babe that it's my
girlfriend that's the love of my life
what do you mean who else did you think
it was yeah it's hot eyes pretty eyes
order what do you mean the love of your
life like that's your that's your misses
yes I thought you knew that I thought
you knew it's Bae it's so obvious it's
actually so obvious you have to try not
to see it yeah what are you on I thought
literally you were choosing not to
mention it this is why I thought we
worked so well yeah that's why I run up
in here clap cheeks and never sleep over
dip
but okay yeah well now you know what is
it what now are we continuing yeah yeah
is anything else anymore for any more or
you're just gonna keep asking me dumb
questions yeah you want to know my mum's
maiden name
what do you want oh my goodness all
right a few more how did you find out
you were the side piece on my birthday I
looked through his phone I saw short he
texted him saying you know this [ __ ] is
yours why would I give it away
huh
on her birthday her birthday this [ __ ]
is yours why would I give it away
because this little Shenanigans is
jarring and boring this celebration
cuddle cuddle kiss kiss it's Jared I
want to go home to eat later I got me a
young takeaway rice at home rags there's
rice at home
yum why would I give it away what was
even that conversation about family
yeah wow wow wow wow cold
I only saw him on Wednesdays and never
wanted to be seen in public with him
that's signed that's bad you should
clock that in two weeks that's fine
still delicious
Midway through sex he said my girl's
[ __ ] could never
care he didn't know where he was yeah
yeah yeah he felt that suction it was
like oh my God it was never never this
is too tight
this is too wet and too tight whoa she
can never she could never that gaping
things she's got this is why I'm on the
market
this is why I'm on the market she's just
looking back what are you saying well
she's just getting clapped what are you
saying bro this is why I'm on the market
wow I'm glad I stepped out I'm glad I
stand out tonight I needed this I needed
this
thank you
she'll be so confused we should be so
turned on shut up and make me a drink
I needed that
I'm parched now oh Jesus
I opened his letter sent to my address
that enlightened me to the fact that he
was paying child maintenance
he had his child maintenance payments to
go into her yard
the remittance this is going to his his
sightings yard what is he on bro he he
messed up yeah he's it must be a team
I'm only Assuming he's done that because
this you is not even his mains
yeah this is a third party yes yes can't
even go to his Mains yard
so we had to redirect the thing to his
side's yard he's in um he's in a
whirlwind of trouble yeah he a whirlwind
of trouble his pipe owns him
wow all right last one
I saw her in a dining hall at lunch with
his jacket around her she turned mine
down the class prior
that's that young love boy wow that's
that heart at Young that's Secondary
School Young Love beige want my jacket
now I'm good I'm good I'm not even that
cold yet I'm not even chilly ignore
these Goosebumps
lunchtime lunchtime next man's jacket
puffer avrax jacket is like oh it's warm
she's just like and you see her from
across the dinosaurs jackets that yeah
is that
you know who this is fam yeah you know
it doesn't fit you but you know it
doesn't fit you brother but yeah welcome
to the show guys guys welcome back thank
you for having us it's Monday fun day
Monday we're back to it and guys if you
want to join us on Thursdays as well
please head on over to patreon.com
forward slash shits and gigs and you
will find years and years of uncensored
super duper fun content over there as
well as a new episode every Thursday
guys it's gonna cost you a very very
very very cheap three pound a month very
very cheap Tempe a day run the pita SMG
and become indoctrinated into the cult
of babies your cult daddies here are
here to show you the way the truth of
always finding the funny having Vibes
and along with that guys you will get an
invite to our pop in Discord server as
well as early bird access to our tickets
to our merch everything on there over on
patreon.com ships and gigs to get on
over there for us please guys if you are
watching us on YouTube guys we are
chasing that one million Subs we're
halfway there Living on a Prayer so
please subscribe to the channel if you
haven't already
and if you are listening on the audio
platforms guys please for the love of
God give us a nice review Firestar is
always preferable whatever you need to
do do it with your chest okay without
any further Ado my comrade firelord
Flags is going to
[Music]
educate us on the happenings of planet
Earth Soul flakes what I wanted to say
the hero Uncle Wrestled a shark to save
nephew severed R have you heard about
this save nephew seven devoted arm so oh
oh oh oh oh oh oh hang on
so the arm's already been yammed and
then he decided to wrestle shock to get
it back sorry cuz
sorry cuz I lied yeah I lied there's
benefits for this
the government has schemes for this the
kind of stuff
on July 6 2001 Jessie an 80 year old boy
from Ocean Springs Missouri was on a
vacation with his family on Uncle
um yeah I'm sorry
what his aunt and uncle Diana and Vance
respectively
um at dust time when Jesse was swimming
in the shallow water in Florida he he
was attacked by a bull shark emerging
about seven foot seven foot oh my God
200 pounds no
as the shock bit off Jesse's right arm
and part of his right thigh oh his uncle
Vance plunged into the water carry the
boy to Shore and dive back in to seize
the shark grabbing it by its tail
he wrestled the shark and dragged it to
the shore where it was shot three times
a seven foot shark he's a liar someone's
lying he wrestled the shark and dragged
it to shore where it was shot three
times in a head and by a park ranger
Jesse's seventh arm between Jesse's
seventh arm between the elbow and the
shoulder was pulled out by the shark's
jaw and was put by the elbow in the
shoulder oh I just clocked [ __ ]
uh was put in a plastic bag and encased
in ice before he was rushed to the
ambulance to the hospital
um on the beach the aunt administered
Jesse's um CPM so cardiopolymer
pulmonary resuscitation to keep him
alive CPR you mean but it's a CPA it
says CPM on here that's so weird
even though it's CPR I don't want to say
CPM on it yeah all right
um yeah uh before he was airlifted his
hospital
um the eight-year-old boy was critically
ill after the nightmare-ish attack
nightmare is shark attack sorry at the
hospital after the 11 hour surgery
Jesse's arm was sewn back on after it
was bitten off by the shark Jesse
recovered slowly from a coma but he
suffered cognitive defects unable to
speak and struggle with and struggles
with severe physical impairments and and
is on a wheelchair at the moment but
thanks to his uncle and also the
emergency team the boy's life has been
saved after one year after the incident
um the uncle spoke to Good Morning
America and he decided to publicly speak
for the first time about rescuing the
his nephew in 2001. 2001 yeah this isn't
2001. geez that was ages ago yeah yeah
um mad bro
that's never happening fam I love my
family I love them
I will jump in and save my nephews yeah
yeah yeah all right I'll say about it
but I'm not jumping back in your arm's
gone let's be real focus on the present
yeah and where can we go forward yeah
yeah the arm's gone I'm not going back
in there let's get him out of here let's
help Jesse out yeah
yeah tie something around the arm to
stop the bleeding let's focus on the CPR
thing I'm not going back in there to
rest a seven foot shark and drag it back
drag it back tail who is he what do you
mean yeah that yeah adrenaline would
have kicked yeah the adrenaline was
controlling him that yeah yeah because
any anyone with any sense is not jumping
in there to get this foolish arm it's
done bro have you seen a shark like
extend its teeth before oh yeah I have
it's the thumbs come out it's not cute
yeah yeah
and where's this Ranger coming with the
gun to shoot why does everyone happen to
be yeah available available just then
and there yeah yeah yes um yeah that's
mad that is crazy bro and dive back in
and say I'm getting that arm back and my
nephew's arm I'm assuming it's just been
yammed oh Rags yeah I've got something
yeah he got Saturn out of it fair play
fair play you know what
you won the battle yeah yeah yeah we're
gonna go home and win the awards Jesse
Yeah yeah especially if he's bleeding
out and he's unconscious and all these
things yeah it's long I wonder if he
thinks that's straight I don't want to
get too dark yeah I don't want to get
too dark hey less yeah I don't want to
take the best but that's that's a Hero
Let's address the facts yeah Uncle Vance
yeah he's a hero real hero a real hero
yeah Jesus would you dive in to save me
I would say yeah I want to go back in
for a body yeah I wouldn't expect you to
go back in yeah I would well if I said
please
that's that's all jargons why are you in
there in the first place
we were all in there
for starters it wasn't just me there's
no scenario where I'm just splashing
around in Missouri
I'm splashing around on my once in
Missouri that's not a real life
situation okay we were all in there and
you saw like me and picked me out he saw
medium rare and took my arm off oh and I
said and then obviously you man dragged
me out yeah and I'm like nah I need it
man damn I'm cognitive enough I'm in
shock yeah I'm like someone get my arm
through her please you're the strongest
swimmer
who had pleased I need it you know what
this life looks for me please get it and
there's a Ranger with a bag of ice ready
he said if you can get it no I'll say
that we can save no I will slap the
ranger in his face he can't swim that's
his problem he's my problem is your
problem but no no I'm not going back in
I promise you I'm not gonna make it all
right say let's say your arm is gone oh
yeah I mean yeah you'd have to firm that
Hill
Rags but it's so
it's so backwards because I'd be
thinking thank God it wasn't me
it's not really as
thank God I couldn't hear you say that
bro I was just after seeing you bleed
out I think [ __ ] God that wasn't me why
don't you just come to after the shock
wears off and you come to the
realization of what you've just
witnessed yeah thank God that wasn't me
I would fight you I'd fight you gotta
ignore at your arm
adnurai
thank God it wasn't me I couldn't hear
those words slap you I'll slap your
Stomp and you'll scream oh no no no no
no you couldn't do that you couldn't do
that because once I'm rehabilitated it's
long for you
once you're rehabilitated because like
yeah we can't be on set with you two
arms and move one and you're right here
saying to publicly thank God it wasn't
me
it's coming I'll smash this thing and
start just start slashing
and you refuse to jump back in and get
my arm
so that's the thing is that I lost my
arm I begged you to get it you said no
no no and then at the end of the day
you're like thank God it wasn't me
because James is suffering yeah yeah and
I didn't help him and I'm just so
grateful that I wasn't the one yeah no
no no no I'm running you over us I'm
doing something
because this is not a disability podcast
and you need to meet the right criteria
yeah say less it's a new year new balls
situation with the global leaders in
below the waist grooming guys this year
take your package to the next level with
their performance package 4.0 and other
premium wet Goods say less wet goods
come on man
inside the performance package 4.0
you'll find the signature lawmer 4.0 the
Advanced Skin safe technology reduces
cuts and Nicks on your delicate Parts it
also comes equipped with the 4000 K LED
spotlight
that will shine a light to the promised
land in
2023. let's go guys you know what to do
by now but if you are new here please
head on over to manscaped.com and use
the code sng Sierra November golf for 20
off and free shipping worldwide let's
get back to the episode thank you very
much boom all right cool right so I've
got a little thing to talk about
um so your boy went to The Last of Us
Premiere yesterday yeah
what's wrong with your face I'm [ __ ]
jealous
sorry G I was jealous as [ __ ] if I'm my
bad bro
um
I'm just gonna say for all you man in
here it's a show fam I know from the
trailer alone I know it's gonna be top
10. it's gonna be the top show of 2023.
already yes
it's amazing I don't watch one episode
I'll only showed one yeah it was like uh
best part of two hours okay it was very
unsources last half an hour I was
thinking because you know obviously when
we go to them they usually show two
episodes yeah yeah
I was like they can't be showing two
episodes I was rubbing my eyes bro I'm
not gonna like the First episodes were
long okay um but
good grief
I haven't played the game but it was
dangerous you can tell by the way it's
shot they mimicked like exact scenes
that happened in the game
wow okay we'll get you from the offset
okay you'll get it from the off set I
love stuff
like I love stuff like oh my God this
guy Atlantic in it yeah yeah they don't
play it's uh hey yes they don't play
yeah they know how to make a television
show HBO don't play wow yeah yeah it's
amazingly good just from episode one is
amazingly good okay I'm gassed yeah yeah
yeah cast it comes out 16 16. so it'll
be out by the time this comes out
yeah is it is it it's Monday the 16th
so it's the 12th now yeah so yeah it is
it comes out when this drops yeah yeah
yeah guys watch it as fast as you can
watch as fast as you can because we're
going to talk about it yeah yeah we're
going to be talking so stay up to date
as fast as you can apparently
actually I'm not even gonna say I don't
even know if I'm gonna say it publicly
never mind okay yeah yeah I don't yeah
yeah they didn't make me sign an India
but I don't I don't want to start saying
stuff I started getting DMs like watch
your mouth
yeah yeah yeah I'm allowing it
episode one is one of the best First
episodes of any season or season series
I've watched it's one of the best
episodes of any series I've watched okay
they hook you emotionally straight away
I don't know how they did it they hook
your mushy straight away
it's a show
good Lord I'm excited to watch it okay I
would advise everyone to watch it
immediately okay okay my accent's up
okay the acting is up yeah it's good
it's good it's like it's giving me like
um
the way they premise it as well it's
like
you can tell because like I said I've
never played the game so I don't really
know how this world works because
obviously like it's almost like post-up
post-apocalyptic so it's giving you like
Resident Evil meets like the Book of Eli
oh my yeah or Mad Max or something like
that so like alongside this whole Zombie
Thing these they've got like a new way
of society which is people living in
this like dystopian
post-apocalyptic World whereas every man
for himself run by like the Army okay
it's interesting and then we've got like
terrorist organizations in there and
we've had they made words of like
obviously so yeah so they've made words
of like there's like slavery people
there's like people that do all sorts so
you're like oh they're Smugglers slavers
terrorists there's all these people okay
yeah bro and then on top of that you've
got the zombies zombies yeah yeah yeah
okay okay it is good okay I'm interested
I was like wow wow not gonna lie the
screen that they chose to use was not
the screen we want to be watching
because it was at the IMAX in Waterloo
have you ever been there I know the
circle one yeah the biggest screen in
the world it's I've never been to a big
I watched the first avatar there I
remember you saying so yeah it's the
biggest screen I can imagine yeah my
neck was hurting big man thing like when
you're watching it yeah
it starts happening over here you have
to turn over here swear it's not what's
happening you have to turn over here
it's long I was missing stuff
there was one point I was watching it
clear as day yeah and Basha did you see
that yeah I said see what he said is
that someone and I was like I said what
and he was like did you see that I was
like what am I watching the same thing
you don't see anything
I didn't see anything I didn't say Shut
up I didn't see anything I was like stop
I want to say stop let's find a normal
screen it's reducing yeah but just I've
had a normal feeling like normal people
yeah why are we trying to show off yeah
I can't see a thing
I don't see a thing
you better do it on split screen yeah if
you can't see anything
how close so far I was a bit too close
oh okay but still I wasn't close close
because there's even between the screen
and the first seat there's a big gap and
I was like
I was a good amount up but still not not
far enough you need if you're gonna if
you're going to that Ms wallet you need
to be the back okay wow
nevertheless yeah
oh okay juicy okay it's going to be the
best show this year okay say less God
I'm excited for you to watch it okay
guys wait this is gonna guys this is
gonna be the show we talk about on a
week a week week by week thing but it's
gonna get a new house of dragon you
heard it here first this is going to be
the new house of dragon it's a shark and
wait for you to watch episode one gang
I'm watching it I'll watch it on Monday
when it comes up
I can't wait speaking of emotion
I've got a movie recommendations you
said you had the swimmers Netflix have
you heard it oh I watched the Syrian
thing
I watched a few weeks ago I forgot I was
going to bring it up and I forgot I
watched it three four days ago true
story no yes emotional roller coaster
yeah I've not seen anything
out before Brother full disclosure
full disclosure I didn't even know Syria
was warm like that warm or warm warm I
knew it was war like that
and oh I knew it this is the only thing
yeah yeah and it was war like that but
all these Oxfam videos they give me the
wrong impression it looked like a Vibe
before these mantora up
did it not
who anyone from Siri who's watching the
show I'm so sorry I can fly before me
it's all right
was hilarious
did you feel safe when you hear about
Siri you just speak mugs
third world a month that's random
because when they um when they actually
got fast forward to that four years
later and they were swimming in that
pool and she was about to like break
some record and he obviously started
seeing something I was thinking these
men can't be in Syria I think they're
not in Syria for sure but anyway guys
premise of the movie is it's based on a
real life story there's two sisters um
what's the name Sarah Ryan
Sarah they're both this good memory I'm
only watching the other day oh okay say
less
something like that used for modini
something like that um Syrian sisters
um and they're both swimmers they're
pops used to swim and he his goal was to
be in the Olympics
um but he couldn't make that gone
because Syria inevitably got into war so
he literally trained his kids to be
professional swimmers and the main chick
his name is yusra she's like the
middleborn
um so the oldest the older sister
resents her quite a bit because the dad
loves the second sister yeah he saw
where the real talent yeah he saw where
the real talent was and the older
sister's just starting to present that
relationship but when
yeah and the water was coming in and
it's gonna capsize we need to lose
weight I need my Dash and Auto close
first of all
first of all I'm not dashing my suitcase
it's all I have that's literally all
I've got because if I arrive on this
beach with nothing on me why did I do
this trip in the first place so first of
all as soon as they started we need to
lighten this up and they were dashing
luggage I would have been like no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no this baby hasn't stopped crying
so what's your point what's your point
I'm acting aside I'm asking you now
what's your waste of space
I've not seen him suck a tit this whole
trip so it doesn't sound like he's gonna
make it
so let's pray over ties
I'm playing I'm playing
I'll play it
but nah there was that was that that was
crazy that was crazy and it's and the
thing just wasn't starting
when it just stopped to the middle of
the ocean wow question yeah would you
have got on the boat
you know when they they were stuck on
the beach about two days yeah and it
came up with some duct tape no I don't
think
[Music]
that's the thing because and then okay
once you realize he ain't coming with
you would you have gone
who's he because the man the smug oh
yeah I'm with you we've got the boat
with you no no no I wouldn't have gone
because he's literally left us defend
for ourselves no no how do we know where
we're going to say go go go go go go
remember slow if fast is trouble yeah he
spoke very little English yeah yeah and
he said fast bad slow Goods Coast Guard
Coast Guard go slow I said what there's
a couple yes that turned straight around
so I'm not getting on yeah yeah he's
gonna drown me I'm Turkish now fat turns
out I'm Turkish now facts because I'm
not making it to Germany yeah on this
I'm not making it yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so long story
short the the aim of the move or the
plot of the movie is two syrians two
Syrian swimmers
um once you get to Germany to swim for
the Olympic or swim in the Olympics uh
Rio 2016 and that is just her lifelong
dreams is to swim in the Olympics but
obviously stuff happened in Syria but
the way they actually depict and show
what it's like to live in a country of
war and try to escape a country of war
is beautiful
literally the emotional roller coaster
is mad it makes you realize people ain't
for people
these men are war-torn let them in yes
let them in when they are hopping fences
and they had German Shepherds up in
there bro oh bro I was like stop I'm
just trying to live fam and then the the
Smugglers are on a little rating that
was West that was West was I wasn't
expecting the evil was I that was West
yeah this is a dangerous game it is this
trafficking game it's dangerous and then
the other brother that said oh um I can
take you to Germany because the other
guys um they're gonna search you and
stop you man just took them and dropped
them off something took them took their
money put them in the truck and just
dropped them somewhere just took them
off out took all their pee everything
bags as well get out get out and have to
start again and then he's just gonna do
a UE and pick up some more and just drop
the same thing nah bro it's taking a
piss taking the piss yeah this Refuge
eating it's long long and as soon as you
get as soon as they get to Germany they
ain't [ __ ] this man had a life in Syria
they had a life in Syria they're
prospects yes family and they left war
and hell and death just for a little bit
of better life and they bring value Let
Me swim for you let me swim for you yeah
yeah and they just put them in some
refugee camp and just like chill chill
yeah you can't do anything your way of
your papers
it could be 18 months that's Madness oh
the whole thing was wild yeah definitely
definitely recommend
um watching the swimmers on Netflix and
obviously like we just said we're going
to be talking about The Last of Us
pretty much for the next two months yeah
yeah we're going to be going for it so
if you're not on it you're against it
bro facts so you're a hater
um right cool you've got trash news for
us okay
um yeah just a quick thing a former
Premier League football I jailed over
gelled over a 15 million pound fraud
scheme
um a former Premier Football has been
charred for defrauding friends and
family in a 50 million pound pyramid
scheme Richard Rufus who used to play
for Charlton athletic was sentenced to
seven and a half years in prison on
Thursday January the 12th the 47 year
old claimed to be a foreign exchange
Trader and convinced people to invest
money in his scheme according to Sky
News Richard used funds from the new
investors to pay back old investors he
then used the rest of the money to fund
his lifestyle
15 M's fraud scheme for friends and
family
just done I've never seen this better in
my life to be fair Charlton he's
I've never seen this better in my life
his name doesn't ring about live by
Richard Ruthie that's probably obviously
before not necessarily before my time
but before I probably knew names like
that but yeah he doesn't ring a bell but
that's that's mad it's also one of those
ones where
it's clear that he was trying to keep up
with the lifestyle that he can't afford
anything yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah he was doing any and everything to
make sure he succeeded
and
yeah look where you are now like that's
it's crazy because
um I feel like it's also a pressure of
like Society because at the end of the
day if you started off I.E as a premier
league footballer there's no way at Hell
in about let's say 10 years time you
just don't want to downsize yeah you you
really don't don't want to dance yeah
yeah what would the you you would be
thinking what would the streets think
yeah by downside literally what are the
streets gonna say I was a baller for 10
years
you need to move locations locations if
you want to download if you're going to
downsize we need to move to the country
yeah yeah yeah yeah
wife just chill and what am I doing
after I get so scared about these kind
of conversations right I think about it
about me and you like every day
what we're going to do after this yeah
oh no it's funny you brought up because
obviously when when I spoke about
um
the side hustle saying well that's
coming out in a few days actually
um that made me think because we've
spoken about this probably a year and a
half ago on the Pod that this was our
side hustle and we said when when this
becomes our main what will be our next
side hustle yeah yeah let's think about
that not too long ago not that I have an
answer for it but it's something I'm
still conscious of yeah I need to have
an answer for it because like I need to
have in my head I need like a sir I
won't say what the figure is but I need
to have like a certain amount of
residual income that's just gonna be
patterned there quite unquote forever
where I'm just like okay okay it doesn't
matter anymore like I'm gonna be
patterned pretty much for life that's
what I need that's as soon as I have
that as like I'm not even good it
doesn't matter if I'm Gonna Be Rich for
life it just means if even if I can make
a handsome income every month for life
it doesn't have to be rich just has to
be I could look after people I can pay
my bills and look after everyone and
still live a comfortable lifestyle as
soon as I can do that and you'll be like
all right cool I can do that forever
but in my head I'm always like cool when
we like obviously we make money and
stuff like that now and I'm like yeah
but for how long like there's a time
limit so every year I'm thinking this
could be the last year let's go let's go
let's go let's go let's go let's go or
it could be less next year the last next
year like these typical like things they
have they make you so much money because
the the
the time frame of the life expectancy of
that career is so short yeah people work
for like 50 60 years yeah and like
you've probably got five good years
scary if you're lucky five good years
you need to make a lifetime income in
that five years terrifies me so yeah
don't be surprised if you see me on
shape our talking up pyramid scheme
because I couldn't downsize
all I was thinking yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah Tick Tock stayed having my name in
their mouth I had to represent yeah I
can't downsize
a con yeah I need that forever money boy
we all do yeah guys moral of today apart
from watching those two shows make sure
you have a side hustle or you know what
your side hustle is going to be even if
I started now plant the seed because
trust me
trust me you're gonna need it scary yeah
yeah as soon as your boss says you says
you're redundant oh this chat gbt is
wiping people off the face of the planet
you're stealing jobs I've seen brief
little things about I've not read into
it but I've read little little nuances
about I was like yeah and this AI game
is taking it over yeah this tragic thing
is murking people it's doing coding it's
doing up scripts it's doing like you can
do jokes for comedians it can do fam if
you need like content ideas
um if you need advertising scheme so
like you could say like if you're a
toothbrush company yeah obviously all
these people hire agencies to write up
um copy to have like the the stuff for
the the ads and all the scripts and the
stuff you could just be like bro write
me a script for
this type of toothbrush with this kind
of humor with like Dad joke humor you'll
write your perfect script bro you don't
need copyrighters anymore wow you could
be like right write me an alternative
ending to flipping Cinderella it will
come up with it
yeah bro write me a movie idea about
werewolves versus vampires
um in a weird like Tibetan Village on
top of Everest and blah here you go full
full movie script yeah it's long it's
actually bro it's long for people scary
it's terrifying they've even done other
things uh as a type of AI now where um
they'll use images from a city so if you
like gave it like images of like LA or
whatever it will figure out exactly what
La looks like the entire city oh wow it
will map out the entire city and the
accuracy is like 99.9 just off the
images that it has it can map out
everything and I'm talking about
everything
it predicts stuff it's scary so it does
like sewer systems Alleyways everything
it will predict so these men that are
doing games like GTA where they've got
like whole C and you've got a whole team
of people mapping out these cities
hey I can do it in a second in a second
so yeah bro the side hustle thing yeah
yeah you need brick or mortar yeah a
couple of couple men are getting
redundant in the next five to ten yeah
oh it's a wrap in the next five years
100 wow bam even doctors
GPS bro GPS up in there they've had uh
they've had to uh chat CBD like diagnose
people here's here's the symptoms hear
their symptoms what have they got AI
bang they've got this to be fair which
actually isn't I don't remember last
time we went to GP you go to GP no
offense guys no fence they go for a lot
of training they deserve the money they
get they work hard Google I'll see them
one day I see them on Google
I see them Googling my symptoms I could
have done that say less yeah yeah I
could have done that say less
um but yeah so it's it's looking long
out here damn yeah they could have
they could have uh you could I don't
know you could go on chat gbt and just
be like Funniest tweets you can think of
cool yeah
cool say less yeah funniest yeah
funniest responses to how did you find
out you were the sighting fair safe safe
yeah that can't run yeah yeah
it's a long story short
benefit in anyone let's say all done
it's not benefiting apart from the man
it's not benefiting anyone it's
benefiting yeah we're for your everyday
yeah we represent every day so let's try
let's shut AI down before he gets out of
control
facts you heard Airfest yeah car man
right I've got a cheeky little thread
that I found the other day you might
have seen it already Okay cool so the
question is what's the most childish
thing that you still do
okay the most childish thing that you
still do
some of these resins yeah what's the
most childish thing you still do yeah
this is Twitter or Instagram uh this I
found it on Instagram it was tweet put
back into Instagram okay okay and these
were the comments okay
um
this one's me pretend I'm in a music
video When I look out the window when
it's raining
all right
that's you that's me sometimes if it's
pouring down with rain
and I've got my hands on the windowsill
and I'm looking out
bro I thought you I thought you were
gonna say pretend you're in a music
video whilst you're listening to music
like walking down the
streets every day you see me do like a
little back step and then just keep
walking I do that every day everyone who
walks past me is an extra yeah
Fox I don't remember the girl in the red
dress
I'm just like I slide through it
sometimes yeah but yeah I do that with
the rain one too okay especially if I'm
in the
carpet it down lean differently you lean
different and you're just like you're
just vibrating you're vibing and you're
just like why did she do it yeah why did
she do it it yeah it's tough
yeah icebox where my heart used to be
um you're just there yeah yeah I'm so
cold I'm so cold I'm so cold
[Music]
say less cool
um
pretend to be asleep when someone walks
in the room
bro I've done that many things bad times
many times facts this one sweeted me if
an unknown number calls me I'm not
speaking first it's going to be a
breathing competition
fun
is that Mr Duncan who's this who is it
speaking speaking who's this who wants
to know
fam
pull the shower back sorry pull the
shower
get your thoughts well that's
embarrassing pull the shower curtain
back just to check
fam
if my ass is exposed I promise you I'm
looking at that door if there's people
in the yard I'm looking at that door
there are times I've been in the shower
and there's people in the yard and I
think did I lock the door
did I lock that door I'm checking and I
want to see if the line is it's vertical
or horizontal and then you start
thinking but is it does locked mean
horizontally
because which way was it yeah yeah which
way is I'm twisted I hate it I panic and
then my wet ass is getting out just to
check
all right cool oh this one's toxic
turn red receipts on when I'm
intentionally ignoring someone
that is toxic turn red receipts on when
I'm intentionally ignoring you I want
you to know that's toxic it's the most
toxic thing I've read it's the most
toxic thing I've read yeah sir you know
it was me it's basically what she's
saying
Rags this one's actually unfortunately
me to a t bro practice an argument
before the argument yeah yeah yeah yeah
racks 100 I play all the rules sad play
all the roles and it never ends up that
way oh right never ends up that way I
think I know that what they're going to
say word for word shower practicing yeah
bro 100 wow I've done it so many that
and you're like do you know how I know
you're wrong you know how I know you're
wrong that's me in the shower dripping
down do you know I know you're wrong
I saw the text
I saw the text [ __ ] it's mad I've
done it bear Time same oh this one I
haven't done this one years but this was
me to a t when I was a you yeah put glue
on my hands and peel it off
like a shedding snake yeah I didn't know
where you were going with this I'm not
gonna lie I I heard what you said but I
didn't register for like three seconds
after yeah you thought I was just gonna
grab my toys I don't know I know where
your head was at I know where your head
was out yeah I remember doing that back
a day yeah bro that's school glue yeah
like yeah seven times yeah oh this one's
me trying to beat the microwave timer
when I've got stuff to do yes yes yes
bro
if I run off and scared on the floor I'm
not trying to hear those three beeps I'm
not trying to hear them say especially
if it's late enough I'm pressing the
button as soon as it beeps when it gets
too late I'm just not trying to hear
that yeah my my microwave now will beep
and beep and beat oh if you don't open
the thing if you don't open it same with
my oven if you set my oven to a timer
once it turns off it's got a
consistently yeah yeah yeah yeah until
you open it just shy I know what you're
doing turn yourself off and I'll get to
you when I get to you
the beef can wait
right
um oh same jump on the grocery shopping
cart for four seconds just to see if
I've still got it all Rags just did a
straight arm yesterday I swear I did
that yesterday
it always goes diagonal for a sec bro
and then you have to land it
I did it on one aisle for like maybe two
seconds and then I snapped back and I
was like 300 you're 31. yeah
you had your 31 stop you're getting
ahead of yourself oh saying I quickly
did a doubt like is anyone about yeah
yeah bro bro
it's the most fun so fun yeah yeah yeah
um
pretend like I didn't hear something all
Rags bro
I'll just be like that
[Applause]
especially when they're talking about me
I had that I was in waitrose the other
day and um I parked up and uh uh
boyfriend and girlfriend clocked me and
I knew their clock to me and then so I
got out went in pushing my trolley and I
see them like coming in an hour and they
were gonna say something I have my
airpods in and then she went hi I kept
staring straight I my face didn't Flint
she was like hi and then I didn't finish
and she was like oh he's got his
headphones yeah it always goes
headphones and I just kept walking I
pretend like I didn't hear [ __ ]
you you plan this summer has I happened
to me better that's why I have my my
ears are getting deformed because I have
my airpods in all the things because it
means I can air you I've had the bad
times like James James keep saying
straight and they're like oh okay oh
okay okay
I think I heard everything yeah yeah
I've got everything yeah
um ah this one's this one's racist and
childish okay talking back to people in
their own accent
oh my God bro
I don't know racist and childhood I
don't think I ever did that in their
Roman accent
um yeah I don't think I've ever did that
yeah yeah that's nuts is not that's not
it is nice that's plight that's
playground stuff that's yeah
bullying wow yeah that's horrible we
used to do that to flat
from Romania but he was cool
he used to have to fly all the time I'm
just gonna Own It Up
um
my boy Mal used to do this all the time
he's a piss me off go into the shop and
touching [ __ ] I'm not buying
he used to do it all the time
touching [ __ ] and not buy it bad anytime
you go to the shop he he loves he used
to love to squish [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah so
if you're walking through Tesco yeah
loaf of bread he's getting in there he's
digging his finger in there malt loaf
digging his finger in there my goodness
all right that's that's childish oh it's
the most childish Donuts cookies he will
pick up cookies to see if they're soft
and put it back you see infuriate me
foreign
[Laughter]
Flapjacks and like bend the tray to see
if it will pop up and then just put it
back
it's a Savage yeah he's an actual Savage
no manners bro zero oh last one me too
A.T yeah yeah shake my foot to help me
get to sleep what
so you know when you're laying there and
you're just like you're gonna shake it
so your body vibrates and it helps you
nah you don't do that never I do that
but I don't do that one but I I hump the
bed if I'm on my front yeah I'll bounce
I'll bounce my body up a little bit okay
so you've got the Reverb okay and then
this it will help you like fall asleep
you don't do that nah as you do that
[Laughter]
so like you could be lying
it's not sensual there's no Arch and
there's no curve it's a whole plank
movement okay so you just bounce on it
so you get some Reverb from the Springs
so it feels like someone's rocking you
to sleep in it oh you just need a little
motion
are you a dog
you think the thing is you think I won't
walk off that
was actually hilarious you know me this
long and you think you can bash me in
front of my peoples and I won't walk off
oh Jesus tell us what the Dilemma is
right guys
um time for the Dilemma of the day my
wife bores me
and she has a bisexual past so I
suggested we open the marriage so I can
date but she's dating men I can't enjoy
dating because I'm concerned with who
she's sleeping with
one guy is trying to replace me oh she
refuses to close the marriage advice Fab
what you guys trying to
wow wow yeah so he thought
my wife bores me you're boring cuz I'm
trying to see something
you like things in it you like things
yeah I like I like things go yeah go
suck some breasts and I'll go suck some
breasts and everyone's sucks everyone's
happy now everyone's happy everyone's
happy there's a brother she's dating us
trying to replace her she won't stop
dating men I'm trying to reclose this
thing and she said
advise me you've opened Pandora's Box
yes sir it's not it's never going to
close advise me
it's a wrap
one of them's trying to replace me one
of them
who he's the main now
he knows about me and he wants my spot
he's the main he's seen them because he
doesn't see a boring at all he's seen
the life I live and he wants this yard
yeah he wants this yard he wants his
yard he wants his picket fence he wants
his whip yeah he wants his Whip and he
wants my girl and he wants me to pay for
it all he wants me to fund his lifestyle
on an alimony thing Madness to me I'm
trying to close it help
that's the reason why you're not banging
not because of hers because of you son
you're boring that's why she's born
because actually you're Buzz
you're actually Buzz
that's the long story short she's boring
because you're Butters Butters and
you're getting no palm and she's seen a
man she's seen a real man and he said
I'll I'll be your husband what's he call
you he calls you boring what did he call
you wow yeah if I was your man I would
never never I would never deserve to be
treated like that come a woman like you
strong woman like you strong independent
woman like letting a weak little man
tell you bald man let me hold you real
quick yeah you're safe in these arms
you're safe do you know you're safe how
you're so light and soft and
um
let's go back to yours I'm tired of
doing hotels you smell amazing today you
smell unbelievable let's go back to
yours come on come on come on hotels are
dead these hotels are dead I want to I
want to get comfortable I want to go
home I want I want to go home is what he
says he could never wanna go home babe
let's go home let's go she would lap
that up as well they love that [ __ ] they
love that [ __ ]
we've done a lot of advice oh I don't
have a word to say you shouldn't have
opened Pandora's Box brother it was your
fault this happened we've done a lot of
open marriage chat open relationship
chat this happens every single time it
does it does every single time the wife
always gets the wife gets clapped and
the bread can't pay for pump can't pay
he's crying downstairs yes and then he
knows about all her Endeavors it's long
bro it is long yeah word of advice just
don't open it never open the marriage
consequences never open the marriage
just cheat just fine yeah
all right don't open the thing just be
ignorantly Bliss
yes
garlic bread yeah there's open thing
yeah unless you're Will Smith is opening
ain't ever gonna work
and even for will it came back to slap
it he came back to slap him August
on a family vacate
listen to me on a family vehicle that's
that's wild a young thing August is a
little younger yeah yeah
I'm sure he's gay am I chatting [ __ ]
August I'll see it I'm sure he came out
gay
I could be spitting Focus I don't know
bro I don't know man let me double check
that but anyway but yeah don't open the
thing
um it's it's bad bad bad bad news
[Music]
um
sorry G and how your wife even later get
back to you that someone's trying to
take your place is wild that's a cry for
help there's a graph help lock it up but
she says we're not closing this thing
because I'm falling in love oh facts oh
yeah yeah so he comes out he's bisexual
all right you just act as well yeah yeah
so that's what I was looking for good
for you man
that's wild anyway
um guys that's it for today it is a
funny episode ping episode thank you as
always and um guys patreon.com shits and
gears catch us on Thursday and love love
[Music]